[Music]
my package from sweden finally arrived
did i just say sweden i'm in uk
i
broke
okay
it works
mid-summer is saved guys
okay
he looks alright
ikea gundam
is safe
this is huge
my alien and odyssey
they made it
nice
[Music]
today's humid which some people would me
consider that it means it's hot
i haven't even noticed to be honest
what is that
a language school
oh
see i'm wearing roppongi that's a cool
shot coming up i'll show you
there's the shine
damn did you just narrow it around
that's so fast i couldn't see it
[Music]
got some nice stuff for my outfit
hanging out
it's gonna be nice
i'm excited
what is this
you punch my test line
is that you giggling whoa
i love those
oh hell yeah they're just doing shrimp
business i could inhale one of these and
i wouldn't even know are these the ones
cute girls like
this one's just green but
they're in a saltwater as a tropical
thing
it's so difficult
first time using etc
is it gonna work
i sure hope it will
oh god i'm nervous let's go slow
shouldn't say something
oh i did
yes
did you hear that oh so faint
me and maya today
is so lovely out
oh my god perfect temperature
it feels so nice maya what do you think
love it she loves it
how you guys doing back there
you know
toyota tesla and all this glory but
just riding it by
[Music]
look at this egg
doesn't he love it
we're looking for a
somewhat tree for our
balcony
yeah we need to pick a tree
there's so many good options here
you like this one
eggy
he gets so many legs
because he's the cutest down
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i finished the gundam by the way
there's a quick build i haven't put the
decals yet but
yeah it looks cool
ikea gundam still the goated but you
know then i finally got my barbell
yeah this place is coming along gray i'm
very happy with it i'll do a tour soon
i'm actually excited for it
coming up
[Music]
how are we doing today
hello
tongue is out huh
tight fit
but we make it work we're at a new
station we've never been to before got
some sandwich how is yours
yeah
look at mine i have a tuna melt how
pretty is this
homemade it's so good
cheers
i didn't realize we had a shark
with us
it's like we in the uk
when you reckon
this dog is so happy today
he's happy to be out
he's so proud look at him
my baby you're my second baby
our parents sent us
alex and marcia here's a moving in gift
for your amazing japan adventure we miss
you both and hope to see you soon
on my camera it looks weird but that's
really cool it lights up like an actual
candle my parents are the sweetest thank
you
thank you mom and dad
it's really cool update on the dementias
she's been doing really good this is
usually the time where she goes a little
crazy
but she's quite calm i think
settling in a bit has helped her a lot
of people in the comments uh say it's
sundowner syndrome which happens to
adults as well when they get older
sometimes uh so we try and tire her out
before she goes crazy and then give her
as much food as she wants and that
she has no reason to complain
so she doesn't get angry
[Applause]
[Music]
what did you order marcia
is that a soup
what did we order
all this amazing assortments
but i got my beans and jelly so i think
i'm the winner here
beans
why is it in jelly
are we in the 70s
[Music]
so
[Music]
good morning
early start today
i'm going to try and get my japanese
driver license feels like i'm going to
work
i'm an hour early better early than late
i guess uh
i
seem incapable of being anywhere on the
right time i don't know what's wrong
with me this is the problem when you're
a youtuber and there's no responsibility
of you being in time i just lost that
yeah i never had it
i can chill for a bit now that that's
nice at least there he is i got it
apparently
this kanji at the top left means 1989
dude my eyes look so blue because of the
background that's so funny that took a
little less than three hours and then
when i want to renew it apparently i
have to
sit through a three-hour course where
they just tell you to be careful in
traffic interesting even though it took
a long time it moved really quickly this
is so many steps so first you have to
stand in line
to submit your documents and then
they'll thoroughly check if all your
documents are correct
that it looked like they were going to
say no to mine for a while but luckily i
had extra stuff so
it was okay
then we had to go and take a photo
then you have to go and resubmit
then you have to wait and then they have
to double check that it was correct and
then you have to wait then you have to
do an eye test
then you have to go and submit that and
then you have to check all the things
again
and then you have to go upstairs then
you have to wait a little bit more and
then you have to collect your your
license then you have to check that it's
correct so yeah it's so many steps it's
crazy if you're not used to that kind of
thing another win
very nice now i gotta head on home we're
outside
in our new
outdoor chairs
but it's rainy season
look at this
we just found a random nice park and
there's no one here
except my
and the pair of shoes i don't know who
they are
whoa and they dance so good
italian dance moves break it down
whoa so good maya loves it
this is so pretty i bet it will be
amazing at night oh my god where's my
shirt going
much yeah you're gonna die i have to
save you this is amazing
they're playing baseball i think maybe
something
hey gary you have to be on your best
behavior okay
promise
i feel personally attacked by that
it's really nice discovering these
random places
here and there
we had no idea this was here yeah the
flowers are coming out
so these are called hydrangeas i think
and they're in season right now
in japan oh this is literally specific
for
oh we're so lucky
i bet this looks awesome at night
i want to see it
[Music]
whoa
holy cow
that's amazing
[Music]
you're my flower maya
[Music]
damn
is it tea
oh i thought it was something
nothing
[Music]
let's go
he's not scared of nothing
[Music]
point oh yeah
[Music]
okay
[Music]
so i finally got my barbell
it's super fun to work out with i love
it
especially leg leg is so much more fun
to do squats and deadlifts but my hands
are not used to it oh my god get some
chunk ken just wrote me because i send
it to him helps a lot okay i'll get some
chalk
[Music]
all right here we are again last time we
drove in this road
i had a measly
pathetic
box car
now
look at me now mom
i got a big ass deal with me we're going
to uh
somewhere marze doesn't know it's a
surprise
i just saw that it was nearby where
we're going anyway so it might be good i
don't know we'll see
windy today
it says it's here but it really doesn't
look like here
this is so nice
oh i see a sign
it's here i found it do you see what
that is
[Music]
[Music]
it's potato huh
they have like duck feet
why don't you come over here ringo
tonight
[Laughter]
[Music]
miss poplar
[Music]
can i have one
that was really fun like i think it was
bamboo thank you yeah there were such a
nice owners and the person that visited
as well it's a little smaller than i
thought but it was still really nice
[Music]
i wanna go in
are these real
no they're not real
so tomorrow's mid-summer so we're gonna
make the flower crayons
so we need some flowers usually you pick
them yourself
but we'll make there
so
what can i say they have really good
sense of fashion here
she said it's the first time she's seen
anyone else with
them internet makes fun of me for having
these shoes but everyone has them here
okay look at these
i'm getting one
[Applause]
[Music]
it fits any parking
that was tight as hell we're going back
to the same park we were the other day
because
we got food this time
because i we think it'll be pretty at
night
why not
it's so well lit but it's still a little
creepy to be here at night
you like it
you like creepy stuff
look at this
what are you getting fried corn
no no no
and this view
[Music]
foreign